san antonio die zweitgrößte stadt in
texas im süden der usa und mittendrin
das bag sah county
untersuchungsgefängnis hier sitzen 4500
insassen ein mehr als im berüchtigten
flori mehr oldies in frankreich dem
größten gefängnis europas
[Musik]
viele der gefangenen warten monatelang
auf den beginn ihres strafverfahrens die
meisten sind erwachsen aber ein blog ist
reserviert für jugendliche straftäter
keiner von ihnen ist älter als 17
[Applaus]
ruf mal die zentrale an
chargen stephany flores arbeitet für das
büro des sheriffs sie kümmert sich um
die sonderfälle bevor sie gesetzeshütern
wurde hat sie in nachtclubs gejobbt
wie geht es ihnen heute
du wolltest mit mir sprechen
es geht um einen anderen officer er hat
mich geschlagen
jemand hat sich geschlagen oder was der
boden er hat mich geschlagen die kameras
gefilmt ok anschuldigungen wie diese
sind an der tagesordnung nichts ist
unmöglich aber im zweifel glaube ich
eher meinen kollegen als die insassen
angeklagte gelten als unschuldig bis das
gegenteil bewiesen ist die
untersuchungshaft ist dennoch knallhart
[Musik]
sie leben sich einfach
liebe ist jedoch nicht der grund warum
diese frauen so eng beieinanderliegen
ist euch kalt ja
deshalb liegt dir so da ja wir versuchen
uns warm zu halten das wissen die auch
gelten sie wirklich als unschuldig
ja aber so behandeln wir sie nicht wir
wollen nicht dass es ihnen bei uns so
gut gefällt sie sollen es sich hier gar
nicht erst möglich machen
sie sollen sich wie im gefängnis fühlen
wenn mich jemand fragt ob sie unschuldig
sind oder nicht zeigt ich bloß auf
dieses abzeichen das steht da drauf
sheriff nicht richter nicht geschworenen
nur sheriff das ist mein job und so
verhalte ich mich auch für mitgefühl
bleibt keine zeit nicht mal gegenüber
den psychisch kranken in sachen
[Musik]
ich soll die tür aufmachen warum
haben sie bitte ob
meine realität existiert ja absolut aber
ich kann die tür nicht aufmachen
schon gut ich muss weiter
die zahl der inhaftierten jugendlichen
in den usa ist höher als die gesamtzahl
aller haftinsassen in deutschland zur
abschreckung gibt es ein schock programm
für gefährdete highschool kids
[Musik]
wir stellen euch auf ihr seid 12 richtig
ok 6 auf die eine seite 6 auf die andere
mädchen hier rüber
in den nächsten stunden sollen sie das
raue knast leben kennenlernen flores
kennt dabei kein pardon
ich sag's euch gleich wir verstehen hier
keinen spaß an die wand
hände auf den rücken
die jugendlichen haben nichts verbrochen
trotzdem bekommen sie das
strafvollzugssystem mit aller wucht zu
spüren das wird ziemlich schnell
ziemlich krass
und das ist erst der anfang nachdem sie
sträflingskleidung angezogen haben
werden ihnen handschellen angelegt
wer hier reinkommt wird wie ein insasse
behandelt
dann geht es zu den zellen ein
ernüchternder anblick
[Musik]
der blick reicht schon
liegen wir auf dem boden und pinkeln
sich voll einfach ekelhaft
also wenn ich das nicht gefällt dann
kommt nicht in den knast das ist mein
rat an euch und
schließlich der höhepunkt des
showprogramms der blog für jugendliche
straftäter er soll die teenager
besonders abschrecken die gefangenen
hier sind im selben alter wie sie selbst
[Musik]
23 stunden pro tag sind sie in ihren
zellen sie dürfen duschen und eine
stunde raus das ist alles
[Musik]
raus heißt allerdings nicht nach draußen
an die frische luft sondern bloß in den
kargen aufenthaltsraum
wir haben hier regeln dieses klo ist nur
für klein dass da nur für groß und das
dafür beides wenn du dich nicht an die
regeln hält gibt es ärger wer hier aufs
falsche klo geht kassiert prügel
kein tageslicht keine uhren wie las
vegas nur ohne spaß um die spannung
aufrecht zu erhalten hat floris einen
spontanen zugriff der gefängnis eigenen
spezialeinheit arrangiert
auf den boden auf den boden
hände hinter dem rücken
der sich da nach unten nicht aussehen
also los mädchen zuerst
die eliteeinheit kommt bei besonders
kritischen situationen zum einsatz
nicht umdrehen gesicht zur wand
dreht euch um zu den
offiziellen spengler hat 16 jahre
berufserfahrung er leitet die einheit
das sind meine jungs ihr wollt ärger
machen die fackeln nicht lange die haben
elektroschocker und pfefferspray für
euch
[Musik]
den stuhl so oder so am ende macht ihr
was wir euch sagen ob der michael sehen
wir jemand gefesselt wird wir machen so
etwas allerdings und dann lassen wir
euch zwei stunden so liegen wenn der
lieutenant mir das erlaubt ist dass wir
weihnachten
bitte
nach der zweistündigen horror tour haben
die schüler einen beängstigenden
eindruck vom knast alltag bekommen
es ist viel härter als ich erwartet
hatte ganz anders als im fernsehen die
geräusche die gerüche alles wenn ich das
sehe will ich auf jeden fall auf dem
richtigen weg bleiben hier will ich nie
landen
nirgendwo auf der welt gibt es mehr
gefängnisinsassen als in den usa und
2,3 millionen amerikaner sitzen hinter
gittern kinder und jugendliche
mitgezählt schon ab zehn jahren können
sie in eine haftanstalt landet
du kannst dein kind doch nicht
wegsperren das ist falsch
[Musik]
130 prozent der minderjährigen hinter
gittern haben gewaltverbrechen begangen
die meisten sitzen wegen kleinerer
vergehen die drogenmissbrauch egal
welche substanz schon kleine mengen
genügen für eine strafverfolgung bei
schwerverbrechen spielt das alter oft
keine rolle kinder werden verurteilt wie
erwachsene und kommen in die selben
gefängnis
ich wünsche keinem 15-jährigen löcher in
den erwachsenen knast geht das leben
dort ist der reinste albtraum
der gefängnisalltag ist von gewalt
geprägt viele der jugendlichen tragen
ein trauma davon
wenn diese kids vor der einzelhaft keine
psychischen probleme hatten dann haben
sie welche danach
manche sitzen in einzelhaft in
fensterlose zellen bekommen wenig zu
essen oder werden geschlagen nach ihrer
entlassung finden sie sich draußen kaum
noch zurecht
meine kindheit mein lebenswille alles
weg
doch einige haftanstalten gehen neue
wege
wir müssen kinder die kinder behandeln
nicht die sträflinge
aber noch ist das die ausnahme in den
usa werden minderjährige straftäter hart
bestraft wer gegen das gesetz verstößt
darf keine gnade erwarten
neuer texas eine einfache kleinen stadt
an der mexikanischen grenze
der bundesstaat texas zählt die meisten
strafgefangenen in den usa
218.000 dreimal so viel wie in
deutschland
darunter sind viele minderjährige die
polizeipräsenz an den schulen ist hoch
bildungseinrichtungen in der region
haben sich zusammengeschlossen um eine
spezielle polizeieinheit ins leben zu
rufen
sie ist extrem gut ausgerüstet gewehre
und bis zu 60 überwachungskameras pro
schule von der mittel- bis zur high
school der leiter der einheit captain
peres überwacht jede bewegung der
schüler
wenn ich wissen will was an den anderen
schulen los ist habe ich auch da zugang
ein klick genügt
was wir sehen ist mobbing
drogenmissbrauch waffen und manchmal
auch körperverletzungen
damit den polizisten kein verstoß
entgeht arbeiten sie ausserdem mit
bezahlten spitzeln
sie melden alle möglichen verbieten zb
diebstähle
ein gemeldeter diebstahl wird mit 40
dollar belohnt eine waffe bringt 200
im durchschnitt wird alle drei tage
jemand festgenommen meist wegen delikten
für die es in europa gerade einmal eine
abmahnung gebe
wir machen das hier drüben bitte nehmen
sie schon mal platzt es geht gleich los
stell dich an die wand ich mach ein foto
dieser 16 jähriger hat im streit um ein
mädchen einen mitschüler geschlagen
nachdem anklage erhoben wurde wird er
jetzt wie ein krimineller abgeführt in
ordnung du hast das recht zu schweigen
und die aussage zu verweigern
jede aussage die du machst kann vor
gericht gegen dich verwendet werden
was ich gemacht habe war falsch der
junge wird nicht ins gefängnis kommen
aber die schlägerei wird ihn sein leben
lang verfolgen das bleibt für immer in
seiner akte
mit einer vorstrafe ist es schwer ein
stipendium oder einen kredit zu bekommen
oder auch nur einen job
[Musik]
die jugendlichen werden ständig
überwacht und die polizisten drücken nur
selten ein auge zu
allein am dieser high school gibt es
sechs polizisten und vier
sicherheitsbeauftragte
sie drehen regelmäßig ihre runden und
kooperieren eng mit den lehrern
fabian arbeitet seit drei jahren in der
einrichtung
wo willst du hin
in deine klasse
ich wollte mal
heute morgen eskortiert er eine
schülerin zum büro des direktors weil
sie geschwänzt hat
was ist los
wieso bist du in meinem büro
du weißt nicht wieso du hier bist du
hast heute schon zwei stunden verpasst
kann ich mich darauf verlassen dass du
jetzt hingehst
salons
zum alltag der polizisten gehört auch
die flur und pausenaufsicht sie sorgen
für ruhe in den korridoren und schicken
die schüler in ihre klassen
[Musik]
so spart euch
wir unterstützen die schüler und
mitarbeiter wir arbeiten mit ihnen
zusammen schließlich tun wir das alles
für die kids sie sollen ihren abschluss
machen dafür sind wir hier in vier von
zehn us schulen ist mindestens ein
polizei aufseher vor ort sie werden vor
allem eingesetzt um den drogenmissbrauch
zu bekämpfen der seit den 90er jahren
stark zugenommen hat in la heuer finden
regelmäßig razzien statt dabei kommen
auch spürhunde zum einsatz
[Musik]
die schulen sind drogen freie zone da
zeigen wir null toleranz
egal welche substanz schon kleine mengen
genügen für eine strafverfolgung
die direktorin der high school
unterstützt das strenge vorgehen die
polizisten begleiten sie zu den
klassenzimmern
wir freuen uns wenn sie kommen das ist
eine gute sache
guten morgen zusammen bitte entschuldigt
die störung
sie beaufsichtigt die durchsuchung der
klassenräume
bitte verlasst alle den klassenraum
lasst eure jacken und taschen hier
für die schüler ist die razzia nichts
ungewöhnliches
das macht die schule sicherer sie ziehen
drogen aus dem verkehr eine
vorsichtsmaßnahme das ist gut für die
gemeinschaft
der hund kennt diese schule schon er
weiß was zu tun ist unter den tischen
nachsehen und das klassenzimmer absuchen
diesmal schlägt der spürhund nicht an
dennoch sind drogen der hauptgrund für
polizeieinsätze in den hiesigen schulen
ich bin auf dem weg zur iss academy mit
einem haftbefehl
office elizondo soll einen 17-jährigen
schüler verhaften er wurde in der schule
mit einer kleinen menge kokain erwischt
ich habe einen haftbefehl
bitte holen sie den schüler raus
hallo wie geht's
erinnerst du dich an die sache im
september
was war da das kleine tütchen
wir haben das eingeschickt und getestet
das ergebnis war positiv auf kokain wir
müssen dich tim richter vorführen
er wird dir deine rechte und die
anklageschrift vorlesen von dort wirst
du dann ins untersuchungsgefängnis
gebracht okay ein schock für den
teenager er hatte bisher noch nie mit
der polizei zu tun
mach dir keine sorgen das ist ein
routineverfahren okay
ich weiß meine mutter bescheid wir rufen
sie jetzt an sie weiß es noch nicht nein
aber wir rufen sie jetzt an können sie
das sofort machen
aber du wirst auf jeden fall verhaftet
egal ob deine eltern davon wissen oder
nicht ob sie ran gehen oder nicht du
wirst nach erwachsenenstrafrecht
angeklagt du bist kein minderjähriger
mehr
in texas ist es möglich kinder ab zehn
jahren zu verhaften und zu verurteilen
mit 17 jahren werden sie von der justiz
wie erwachsene behandelt
die direktorin dieser high school
unterstützt das strengere durchgreifen
in dem alter wissen sie ganz genau was
sie tun sie müssen deshalb zur
verantwortung gezogen werden wenn ihr
verhalten keine konsequenzen hat machen
sie einfach weiter wie bisher
der junge mann wird ins
untersuchungsgefängnis gebracht dort
wird der fotografiert und muss seine
fingerabdrücke abgeben
hast du angst
ja
so was habe ich noch nie durchgemacht
noch am selben abend kommt er wieder auf
freien fuß aber beim nächsten vergehen
landet er direkt hinter gittern
[Musik]
als einziges land der welt haben die usa
der un kinderrechtskonvention nicht
zugestimmt darin ist geregelt dass
minderjährige nur eingeschränkt
schuldfähig sind in den vereinigten
staaten dagegen kann ein jugendlicher
straftäter nach erwachsenenstrafrecht
angeklagt verurteilt und zusammen mit
erwachsenen gefangenen eingesperrt
werden
[Musik]
brasilia texas 500 kilometer nördlich
von la heuer das verschlafene nest ist
berüchtigt für seine haftanstalt eine
der ältesten im ganzen land vor zehn
jahren wurde austin evers soll hier
eingeliefert damals war er gerade einmal
das kamerateam darf ihn eine stunde lang
interview unter aufsicht er war soll
muss noch 30 jahre wegen mordes an
seinem vater absitzen
ich habe ihn erschossen ich dachte mein
leben wäre ein gefahr
er hat gedroht mich umzubringen und er
hatte ein messer
da bin ich ausgerastet
diesmal nicht getan
[Musik]
in seiner kindheit wurde er was soll
fast täglich von seinem vater geschlagen
und gedemütigt
ich dachte wenn ich ihn umbringen ist
das alles vorbei und ich kann ein
besseres leben führen keine ahnung so
denkt man halt als unreifer 15-jähriger
schlecht beraten unterschreibt aber soll
damals eine vereinbarung die ihm sein
pflichtverteidiger vorlegt ohne
gerichtsverfahren wird er zu 40 jahren
gefängnis verurteilt so kommt er nach
brasserie
[Musik]
ich war noch so jung und dann waren da
all diese typen manchmal dachte ich oh
der selber cool oder der da erinnert
mich an meinen dad das war natürlich
schlechte vorbilder
ich bin von kriminellen umgeben harte
typen die immer wieder hier drin nannten
[Musik]
statistiken zufolge haben jugendliche
gefangene ein fünfmal höheres risiko
vergewaltigt zu werden ihre
selbstmordrate ist zehnmal höher als bei
erwachsenen gefangenen
den erwachsenen knast wünsche ich keinem
15-jährigen den wünsche ich niemandem
das ist der reinste albtraum für die
gefangenen genauso wie für ihre
angehörigen
[Musik]
bei seiner entlassung wird er was soll
55 jahre alt sein
[Musik]
ob sich der harte kurs der texanischen
behörden wirklich auszahlt ist
zweifelhaft
die zahl der drogendelikte nimmt immer
noch zu und die rückfallquote beträgt 42
prozent immer öfter wird die seit 30
jahren praktizierte
null-toleranz-strategie kritisch
hinterfragt
[Musik]
der us bundesstaat utah im westen
nordamerikas
hier hat ein grundlegendes umdenken
stattgefunden
eine strafrechtsreform hat das ziel die
zahl der jugendlichen gefangenen zu
senken und stattdessen in deren
rehabilitation zu investieren
am fuß der rocky mountains liegt die
stadt oktan mit ihren 90.000 einwohnern
hier befindet sich die jugendhaftanstalt
mit krieg
[Musik]
hinter diesem zaun leben rund 60
jugendliche zwischen 12 und 20 jahren
sie sitzen wegen schwerer verbrechen wie
mord raub überfall und drogenhandel ein
[Musik]
heute spielen sie eine partie im
american football gegen ein anderes
gefängnis team undenkbar in anderen
teilen der usa
[Applaus]
die frau hinter der strafrechtsreform zu
sind berg
das ist ein ganz neuer ansatz wir müssen
kinder wie kinder behandeln nicht wie
strafgefangene wenn wir sie so nennen
werden wir sie auch so behandeln wenn
wir sie jugendliche nennen und ihnen die
chance geben sich weiterzuentwickeln
verändert sich auch unsere haltung innen
gegenüber
ein ehrgeiziges ziel besonders wenn man
bedenkt dass 90 prozent der jugendlichen
gangs angehören anders als in den
meisten gefängnissen werden mitglieder
verfeindeter gangs hier nicht getrennt
das führt immer wieder zu spannungen
[Musik]
es gab einen streit in der turnhalle ich
habe es gewusst
shera arbeitet seit 15 jahren in der
einrichtung sie weiß dass die
jugendlichen jetzt schnell getrennt
werden müssen sonst droht die lage zu
eskalieren
ok jungs aufstellen bitte
der 15 jährige john hat einen anderen
jungen geschlagen er sitzt wegen 67
solcher und ähnlicher übergriffe am ende
sind sechs wärterinnen und wärter nötig
um ihn unter kontrolle zu bringen
[Musik]
shera kennt solche situationen im dienst
trägt sie weder uniform noch waffe
sie sieht sich eher als erzieherin
das war kein gang
ich will das gar nicht sehen
geht mir der hand so so gibt man sich
die hand wir machen das aber so dann so
in geres gruppe sind rund 15 jugendliche
ich betrachte sie nicht als gefangene
als weist dann als bewohner das hier ist
eine sichere einrichtung für kids kein
gefängnis
zu den kids gehört auch der 17 jährige
roche auch er ist mitglied einer gang
und seit einer woche hier wegen
entführung und schweren raubüberfalls
eigentlich sollte ich in einen
erwachsenen knast 15 jahre bis
lebenslänglich aber ich habe widerspruch
eingelegt
ich bin ja noch minderjährig dann haben
wir uns geeinigt
die vereinbarung hängt jetzt wie ein
damoklesschwert über rossis kopf wenn er
während der haft probleme macht droht
ihm eine lebenslange strafe in einem
erwachsenen gefängnis
deine mama macht sich sorgen
auseinandersetzungen zwischen gang
mitgliedern gehören zum alltag
hey du kennst mich salt lake city scheiß
auf den rest so sieht's aus starb starb
shera geht dazwischen damit rossi nicht
in schwierigkeiten gerät
er hat großes gang geht ist also groß
wie weg damit es keinen ärger gibt
das ist meine zelle muss er hat seine
eigene methode um ruhig zu bleiben ich
bete dass hier sind die wochen ziele
an die regeln
wenn du jemanden den du vertrauen kannst
also von den wärtern meinig und
respektiere alle
das habe ich gemacht läuft also
als neuankömmling wird rossi rund um die
uhr von einer kamera überwacht
sie wollen wissen ob ich mich umbringe
oder so komisches gefühl der ist immer
an da oben wir können wir bei allem zu
gucken
in der zelle ist alles gesichert
das ist kein glas oder metall damit man
sich nicht mit scherben verletzten kann
das wollen die nicht und die zahnbürste
ist so kurz damit man kein messer daraus
machen kann
wie in vielen gefängnissen ist gewalt
allgegenwärtig
guck mal egal wann egal wo
kommen nach utah dann kriegst du das
hier
die meisten der jugendlichen hier sind
schon früh einer ging beigetreten jose
kam mit 13 zu den souvenirs gibt kaum
etwas anderes übrig
meine ganze familie ist dabei eine ganze
familie ja alle
verkaufs drogen alle desktops es war bin
ich hier drin
musstest du das machen ja sonst schlagen
sie einen zusammen
ich wurde mal von der ganzen gang
verprügelt weil ich eine pause wollte
ein paar gebrochene rippen ein
gebrochenes schlüsselbein
ein paar ausgeschlagene zähne im kiefer
musste verdrahtet werden ich hatte eine
gehirnblutung und meine kniescheibe
wurde mit einem baseball schläger
zertrümmert
dafür könnte nicht weglaufen doch das
kann man wenn ich raus kommen dass es
wieder so laufen aber ich werde schlauer
sein und lass mich nicht erwischen
er muss ich
das ja nicht überleben will münster
zurück ganz ehrlich ich will lieber bei
meiner familie
die jungen männer sind in einer nahezu
ausweglosen lage
her wenn ziehst du ein grünes an um
ihnen zu helfen setzt die anstalt auf
bildung
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
wie gewöhnliche teenager in den usa
gehen auch sie jeden tag zur schule der
unterricht findet in der haftanstalt
stadt
rechte seite jungs
für jose beginnt der tag mit biologie
heute steht genetik auf dem lehrplan
[Musik]
er bitte
alle organismen bestehen aus zellen der
lehrer müsste thompson weiß wie er die
klasse bei der stange hält
euer körper besteht aus zellen okay
wenn die polizei an einem tatort nach
dna sucht und hält sie ausschau nach
zellen vom körper des täters
als nächstes steht ein experiment mit
zahnstocher und glasplättchen auf dem
plan daraus ließe sich auch schnell eine
waffe machen
in den mülleimer wirft das weg und
versucht ja nicht etwas zu klauen
wenn wir mit materialien arbeiten sei es
glas oder metall oder auch nur ein
zahnstocher achten wir darauf dass die
kids nichts mitnehmen
shera assistiert thompson sie passt
genau auf
ich behalte sie die ganze zeit im auge
besonders ihre hemmten ich prüfe ob sie
etwas in die hose gesteckt haben
außerdem dürfen sie keine stifte
mitnehmen
12345 ich habe 6
[Musik]
mit hilfe eines punktesystems wird
vorbildliches verhalten belohnt
[Musik]
wer gut mitarbeitet darf länger draußen
sport machen
oder an martys kursen teilnehmen er ist
ein therapeut mit einem besonderen
ansatz
[Musik]
egal was um dich herum passiert wenn du
frieden hoffnung und respekt in der
trägst wird ihr gutes widerfahren
neben der meditation gehören martys
sportstunden zu den beliebtesten
angeboten
etwas tiefer ich passe auf
die jungen männer wollen sich mit ihren
muskeln respekt verschaffen
[Musik]
das gilt besonders für chris den
jüngsten in der gruppe er ist gerade
erst 14 geworden und wird oft gehänselt
esther süss ne lachnummer
weil der junge er sieht aus wie ein
unschuldiges kind
[Musik]
er muss stärke zeigen um hier über die
runden zu kommen
ich trainiere meine brustmuskeln du
willst stark sein ja warum einfach so
mich zu wehren
therapeut marty verfolgt andere ziele er
will den jungen selbstbeherrschung
beibringen
viele von ihnen sind als kinder
misshandelt und vernachlässigt worden
das führt zu problematischem verhalten
durch das training lernen sie ihre
körperlichen reaktionen und ihre gefühle
in den griff zu bekommen und sich
insgesamt wohler zu fühlen
danke martin
[Musik]
dieser umfassende weichere ansatz ist
vielversprechend
in utah ist die rückfallquote rückläufig
ob andere us staaten nachziehen werden
bleibt abzuwarten in den letzten jahren
haben die vereinten nationen das
us-amerikanische gefängnissystem
mehrfach für seine foltermethoden
kritisiert
[Musik]
auch in new york sind die zustände kaum
tragbar hier sitzen jugendliche
straftäter oft monatelang in einzelhaft
der big apple mit seinem berühmten
wahrzeichen der freiheitsstatue
ganz in der nähe liegt eine art modernes
alcatraz die gefängnisinsel rikers
island mit ihrem 10 haftanstalten
[Musik]
insgesamt sitzen dort bis zu 17.000
männer und frauen darunter auch
minderjährige die auf ihr urteil warten
hinter diesen mauern geht kalif browder
durch die hölle sein fall schockiert die
öffentlichkeit 2010 wird der damals
16-jährige zu unrecht beschuldigt einen
rucksack gestohlen zu haben 1000 tage
lang wartete er auf seine verhandlung
bei der er schließlich freigesprochen
wird
während dieser zeit hat er wiederholt
von mitgefangenen angegriffen
[Musik]
diese aufnahmen zeigen wie er von
mehreren insassen verprügelt wird
weil sich browder keiner ging
anschließend will ist er frei wild
einige wachen versuchen ihn zu schützen
während andere grundlos auf ihn
einschlagen
[Musik]
zu seinem schutz kommt er schließlich in
einzelhaft in das berüchtigte loch
[Musik]
zwei jahre lang verbringt er jeden tag
23 stunden in einer zelle so groß wie
eine parklücke zur außenwelt hat er kaum
kontakt
mehrmals versuchte sich umzubringen
[Musik]
der 16-jährige kalif browder kam von
einer party in der bronx als die polizei
ihn wegen diebstahls festnahme nach
bruders freilassung sorgt seine
geschichte für schlagzeilen eine debatte
über die schrecken der einzelhaft
entbrennt
sie geben einem nicht genug zu essen du
kriegst drei portionen pro tag hast aber
trotzdem die ganze zeit hunger das
wahrscheinlich teil der strafe wenn dann
noch eine portion weggelassen wird
machte ich das richtig fertig
hatten sie oft hunger
sehr oft das könnte ich nicht mal zählen
sowas passiert jeden tag es muss
aufhören dass unschuldige leute weg
gesperrt werden
der bürgermeister von new york city hat
angekündigt reckers island innerhalb der
nächsten zehn jahre zu schließen zu spät
für kalif browder zwei jahre nach seiner
freilassung begeht er selbstmord
in gedenken an ihn wird eine straße nach
ihm benannt
barry user kennt das knallharte system
von innen auf rikers island war sie in
dem gefängnis blog tätig in dem die 500
einzelzellen liegen user dort acht
monate als psychiatrische assistentin
gearbeitet was sie dabei erlebt hat sie
bis heute traumatisiert
[Musik]
wenn diese kids vorher noch keine
psychischen probleme hatten dann haben
sie spätestens jetzt welche oft waren
sie blutüberströmt weil sie sich selbst
verletzt hatten
blut verschmierte wände manche schlugen
sich die köpfe an den wänden ein bis zum
schädelknochen
[Musik]
andere versuchten sich eine schlinge zu
knüpfen
wieder andere waren komplett weg
getreten und brabbelte nur noch
sinnloses zeug oder waren mit kot fall
geschmiert es war schrecklich sie so zu
erleben
einzelhaft hat schreckliche auswirkungen
auf die menschliche psyche
einzelhaft greift den verstand an die
leute werden depressiv sie führen
imaginäre gespräche mit den wänden oder
mit ungeziefer
sie sind voller angst
nach einer weile können sie nicht mehr
mit anderen kommunizieren sie verlieren
den sinn für die realität
sind verzweifelt
denken an selbstmord
es ist extrem
inzwischen gelten im mehr und mehr us
bundesstaaten erleichterter
haftbedingungen für minderjährige
doch ein drittel setzt nach wie vor auf
uneingeschränkte härte jugendlichen die
diese hölle überstehen finden nur schwer
ins normale leben zurück
nördlich vom central park liegt der
stadtviertel haarlem ihr leben vor allem
afroamerikaner diese bevölkerungsgruppe
hat ein fünf mal größeres risiko
festgenommen zu werden als ihre weißen
mitbürger
[Musik]
virgin alt und seinem cousin wurden hier
geboren
das ist halt das beste viertel der
ganzen stadt
die leute stellen sich gern auf
aber gangster zeug ist nicht angesagt
das läuft hier nicht
mit 16 wurde rational zu unrecht wegen
mordes angeklagt er verbrachte sechs
jahre auf rikers island die hälfte davon
in einzelhaft während er auf sein urteil
warten
das gefällt mir
nach seinem freispruch wurde er im
februar 2018 entlassen seitdem versucht
er wieder in der gesellschaft fuß zu
fassen
manchmal reagiere ich als wäre ich noch
im knast ich werde nervös mag keine
menschenansammlungen
händeschütteln und leute anfassen nein
das geht nicht das macht mir angst das
ganze soziale leben verdanke ich dem
knast ich war so lange allein
[Musik]
in der nachbarschaft viele seiner
freunde haben ebenfalls mit einer
einzelzelle auf rikers island
bekanntschaft gemacht
er war auch als jugendlicher drin ja ich
war damals 18 er war vor mir dran von
zehn jahren dass ich vielen einzelhaft
aufgewachsen in einzelhaft
da musst du mental stark sein sonst
bringst du dich um das ist theater drin
deswegen drehen viele durch da herrscht
große feindseligkeit und aggressionen
niemand will da rein das ist wie ein
knast im knast
darin kannst du total verrückt werden am
ende fressen manche ihre eigene scheiße
kommt ständig hoher
das 50 km
die jahre im gefängnis haben bei
reginald narben hinterlassen nicht nur
psychisch sondern auch körperlicher
natur habe in seinem gesicht stammt von
einem mitgefangenen
[Musik]
ich komme hier ständig
spielen sie auch mal nein ich habe
gespielt als ich jung war
heute habe ich schmerzen in den beinen
weil ich mich in der zelle so wenig
bewegen konnte da ist ein spalt in
meinem bein
als ich rauskam fühlte es sich an als
wäre etwas sinn mehr gestorben
eine kindheit mein lebenswille meinen
lebensfreude
[Musik]
reginald ist arbeitslos seine
körperlichen handicaps machen es ihm
schwer einen job zu finden
solange er arbeit sucht wohnt er bei
seinem cousin
[Musik]
wie ein drittel aller jungen leute die
im gefängnis fahren ist er an
depressionen erkrankt er braucht
medikamente um einschlafen zu können am
meisten aber leidet er unter der wut die
ihn nicht loslässt hier sagt
[Musik]
darin macht man vieles was draußen nicht
geht
gegen die tür hermann
sich wie ein tier benehmen
wenn du dann raus kommst kannst du kaum
glauben dass du das alles gemacht hast
ich will kein aggressiver hasserfüllter
mensch sein aber manchmal bin ich
grundlos voller hass und weiß nicht
warum ich
fühle mich immer noch wie mit 16 ich bin
nicht richtig erwachsen geworden ich war
verloren und ich bin es immer noch ich
konnte mich nicht entwickeln
man kann ein kind doch nicht einfach
wegsperren das geht nicht es ist doch
noch ein kind
[Musik]
jeanette hofft vom staat new york
schadenersatz zu bekommen
[Musik]
zurück im us bundesstaat utah der seinen
strafvollzug system reformiert hat um
die zahl jugendlicher gefangener zu
senken
[Musik]
im müll krieg startete jüngst ein neues
programm
jugendliche die auf die schiefe bahn zu
geraten drohen werden von der polizei
den eltern oder sozialdiensten
vorsorglich in eine art bootcamp
geschickt damit sie nicht irgendwann im
gefängnis enden
der ahnungslose mike wird gerade von
seiner familie abgeliefert sofort bricht
der 13 jährige in tränen aus
scheiß laden
mikes mutter und großmutter sind besorgt
über sein verhalten deshalb haben sie
beschlossen ihn her zu bringen
er gerät außer kontrolle
er legt feuer ist aggressiv und wütend
er glaubt meine zigaretten raucht sie im
haus und drückt sie auf seiner matratze
aus
wir wollen nicht dass er im gefängnis
endet denn im moment ist auf dem besten
weg dahin
mike wird für die maximale dauer hier
bleiben 30 tage
zu unserem programm gehören auch kurse
im jugendzentrum
aber die sind freiwillig er muss da
nicht mitmachen
da geht es um emotionale selbstkontrolle
habe ich gemacht
okay ich gehe dahin
mike hat atembeschwerden
er will nicht von seiner familie
getrennt werden und klammert sich an
seinen kuscheltieren fest
ich hab dich lieb
zunächst muss mike einen
persönlichkeitstest machen so wird
festgelegt welche betreuung er bekommen
soll
hast du betrunken oder bekifft etwas
getan dass du bereust ja hast du schon
einmal an selbstmord gedacht ich habe
mit ja geantwortet
stimmungsschwankungen
definitiv depressionen definitiv
atembeschwerden
zählt es wenn ich bei einem wutanfall so
artner nein das haben wir schon okay
mike hat mit drogen und psychischen
problemen zu tun er versteht genau worum
es bei der befragung geht es geht darum
ob ich hier sicher bin oder ob eine
strengere einrichtung besser für mich
wäre
dann bitte deine tasche ich mache auf
dies ist nicht sein erster aufenthalt
mike kennt sich bereits aus
ich hole mir dein bettzeug danke
das bett ist aus holz mitteilten sind
verboten die haben teile mit denen man
sich verletzen kann
die matratze ist aus schaumstoff
damit kann man sich nicht ersticken oder
aufhängen
ziemlich eng hier wie in einer zelle
mikes verhaltensprobleme hängen mit
seiner familiären situation zusammen
sein vater ist drogenabhängig und
derzeit obdachlos
weißt du warum du so wütend weil man
denkt nicht da ist das ist traurig ich
will nicht hier sein aber es wird mir
gut tun
hast du angst vor dem gefängnis
ehrlich gesagt ja die würden mich da
wahrscheinlich verprügeln außerdem
darfst du da keine zahnbürste haben weil
man daraus er besser machen kann
die jugendlichen sind alle aus ähnlichen
gründen hier drogen misshandlung gewalt
[Musik]
mike hat sich mit zum empfang
angefreundet sie ist 15 und sucht schutz
vor ihrer gewalttätigen mutter
[Musik]
wie geht es euch her ich fühle mich
sicher ist so
was gibt es da zu lachen
ich fühle mich wie in einem käfig aber
die gute seite
das ist kein guter käfig
mike hat oft probleme mit gleichaltrigen
hast du freunde draußen weil weil ich
ein böser junge bin glaubst du das
wirklich
keiner will was mit einem zu tun haben
der raucht und drogen nimmt und so
[Musik]
sein drogenproblem wird hier wohl kaum
besser werden
jeden abend muss er eine ganze reihe von
tabletten nehmen
auf serien leslie überprüft ob er auch
wirklich alle heruntergeschluckt hat
in die richtung was sind das für
tabletten
zum schlafen wegen angst depressionen
gut abends nimmt er sechs und morgens 4
das ist eine menge
in den usa werden verhaltensauffällige
jugendliche nicht bloß weg gesperrt oft
werden sie mit starken medikamenten
ruhiggestellt
nebenwirkungen inklusive
nein
woher weißt du dass ich glaube es
jedenfalls nicht
trotzdem fragt er nach weiteren
tabletten
haben sie melatonin
wir können morgen die schwester fragen
ohne melatonin kann ich nicht
einschlafen melatonin ist ein hormon das
den tag-nacht-rhythmus steuert
[Musik]
ich habe mit seiner mutter gesprochen
sie sagt du kommst auch mal ohne aus
das ist doch mist ohne kann ich nicht
schlafen sie sagte du schaffst das
morgen kommt sie vorbei
ich kann ohne dass zeit nicht schlafen
wir werden öfter nach ihm sehen als
sonst es geht eben nicht gut er könnte
sich was antun
fast eine stunde lang kommt nicht zur
ruhe er will sein melatonin und lässt
nicht locker
du hast keine ahnung was ich durchmache
also seid still
leslie war es nicht weiter sie ruft
erneut seine mutter an
manni kommst du
warum zur hölle hast du mir die pillen
nicht mitgegeben das ist seine pflicht
als mutter und erziehungsberechtigte
das ist deine schuld du hast mir
schließlich hier eingeliefert deine
schuld
[Musik]
und 23 uhr schläft mike endlich ein ohne
melatonin er nimmt immer noch an dem
programm teil wohnt aber inzwischen
wieder zu hause er hofft dass er nie
wieder hier her muss
von ihren familien getrennt und aus der
schule gerissen werden jugendliche
gefangene in haftanstalten traumatisiert
die gewalt die ihnen dort wieder fährt
gefährdet ihre entwicklung und fügt
ihnen lebenslange narben zu sie kehren
als verlorene in die gesellschaft zurück
und rutschen oft wieder in die
kriminalität ab
[Musik]